- During the last days I was at home here
in North Rhine-Westphalia
in the west of Germany.
Was really great to spend a couple
of days together with
my family, my sisters,
my parents, my wife, our baby girl,
just here at home recharging
the batteries a little bit.
And just talking,
having some great
interactions with the family.
Always, awesome and feels
like a little mini holiday.
So I whilst thinking about the topic,
that I wanted to talk about today.
And I remembered a
LinkedIn post that I wrote
a couple of weeks ago.
By the way, feel free to follow
me on my LinkedIn as well.
I will blend in my socials in here.
But this post was about my twenties.
So as you might know, at the moment,
I'm in my very early thirties.
So my twenties are now behind me.
And I was reflecting
what were the learnings,
what were the lessons and insights
that I got out of my twenties.
And because I did get
quite a lot of positive
feedback from you on the posts.
I thought, let me expand on that
in a proper YouTube video.
Because I felt like this post
was not even close to getting
into the details into everything
all my thoughts about this topic.
And to provide a little
bit of context on my 20's,
let me just start by talking
about what my twenties were like.
How all of this worked.
And when I was about 19,
I finished high school
here in a rather rural area
in the west of Germany.
In high school, I was always a solid,
but not a great student.
I had a solid high school degree,
but not nothing extraordinary.
But what I always knew
is that I was interested
in business and likely in the future,
I did want to work in business indeed.
So I was looking for good
universities in Germany to study
business and preferably also
rather far away from home.
Because I felt like this was
what I needed at the time.
A new start, a new environment,
where I wanted to grow and study.
So I decided for the university of Munich,
I always loved the city.
The university seem great
and what's even better
is that this university offered
me the opportunity to
not only study business,
but also philosophy imperative.
This was a topic I was always
interested in during my youth.
And I felt like it was a
great opportunity to also have
exposure to this slightly different topic.
Then I started two independent
bachelor's in parallel,
one in business, one in philosophy.
So as you can imagine,
that was quite a special
and rewarding environment
as I found myself in.
So surely the typical business student,
is a very different personality
than the typical philosophy student.
In business we talked
about maximizing profit,
setting up in your
business in the best way.
In my philosophy seminars,
it was not unusual,
that students starting to
debate whether communism
wouldn't be a great
form of society as well.
Was also during the end
of my undergraduate degree
that I had the opportunity to
do the internship at McKinsey.
And then after that,
I got the offer to join McKinsey
full-time as a consultant,
after my master, but I
did not even start yet.
So clearly then it was
really a great feeling
to start in London at the
London School of Economics,
for this accounting and
finance master that I did,
already knowing that afterwards
I had the opportunity
to then join consulting,
which surely took a lot of
pressure out of my shoulders.
So after my master,
I was 23 years old when I joined McKinsey,
first in the Berlin office.
And I spent a couple of
years of working there
after this time in consulting.
Which I think is very well documented
throughout all the videos on my channel
and then took the so-called
educational leave,
which usually the MBB firms offer.
So this is a timer,
you can do an MBA or a PhD or even both.
So this is the opportunity
that then I took as well.
I did my MBA at INSEAD
which surely was a great
and amazing experience as well.
I spend half of the
time, roughly in France,
the other half of the time in Singapore,
using the opportunity
to travel through Asia.
I remember like a two week
course that we had in China.
I remember two week course that we had
in the Silicon valley,
where we all flew there.
If you're interested to
hear more about that,
just write me a message.
And I'll create maybe a future video,
where I just fully talk
about my MBA experience.
After the MBA,
I spent some additional
time working on my PhD,
and then I came back to McKinsey
to spend some additional
time working as a consultant.
And this was then when,
at some point I was 28, 29,
were then I decided to leave McKinsey,
leave consulting started a medium sized,
retailer in Germany as a CTO position,
which is then where pretty
much my twenties ended.
And now, as you know,
this year transitioned to
even a new role as a CRO.
So chief revenue officer
and a mature start-up here in Munich,
which is what I'm currently doing.
So if you're interested more on that,
what a typical day in
this new role looks like.
I recently created a video,
I will link it somewhere above here.
Check it out to know
what this is all about.
So I hope that this helps to give a little
bit of context of what my
twenties were all about,
but not before we dive
into what my lessons
and insights are,
what are the things are
that at least I hope,
might be helpful to some of you as well.
Let me first start by
properly greeting you here.
So welcome come to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and on my channel I want to help you,
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
So for those of you who are watching
the first time, on my channel,
I talk a lot about
consulting related topics,
career topics, generally reflections
that hopefully help people probably
around the mid twenties
to maybe the mid thirties.
To grow as a person and as a professional,
but now let's really dig into it.
So what are the insights
that I got from my twenties,
from what happened to me in
the early parts of my life?
The first reflection I would
love to share with you is to
think about what the typical pathway is,
that a similar person
like you will likely take.
And I think about how
you can actively expose,
yourself to rather unusual situations
and try out new things,
that most other people in your environment
will likely not have the opportunity
or will likely not have
the willingness to do that.
So think about that, what
will a typical person,
more or less similar to you likely
do at the start of their twenties.
Well very likely they
will move to another city,
start studying at university.
Will put some time into
learn for the exams.
Try to write at least decent grades
or occasionally go out
with friends, go partying.
Of course, have a good time.
Maybe at some point do a semester
abroad than start a solid
job during the mid twenties or so.
Then start earning some decent money
and then growing their career from there.
So this is likely the baseline
of activities that you should
and will do in your twenties.
And of course, I'm very
well aware that this
is very privileged already
and likely there will be many,
many people in the world who
do not have the opportunity
to do even this.
So surely if you do this,
this is what likely the majority
of the people in your environment will do.
And the result of that will be,
if you only do this,
that you will get more or less
the same things that all the
other people in your surrounding will get.
I'm not saying that this is a bad thing,
but as I know that many
of you are very ambitious
and do want to achieve maybe a little bit
more than the average of your peer group.
Here are the key question that
you should ask yourself is,
what can I do on top of that?
What are experiences I can expose myself
that will add to my learnings,
add to my reflections will
help me really develop my
personality, develop myself as a person.
So reflecting on my twenties,
I can only say that some of
the experiences that helped me
the most were exactly these experiences,
which were maybe a little bit unusual.
Maybe a little bit
leaving the beaten path,
to do some additional new things.
And in the show I already
talked about studying,
philosophy in my undergraduate
as an additional degree.
This definitely was not something
that many other people did.
Also decided by university studies,
to join the student group.
So in Munich there's the
so-called CDTM program,
Center for Digital
Technology and Management.
It's an additional honors degree,
that you do on top of
your regular studies.
It's a lot about entrepreneurship,
building new projects,
developing products,
marketing them, doing sales for them,
how entrepreneurship works,
how you raise money for a start-up idea.
This was all additional work.
Lots of time, in my evening,
I probably invested at least
as much time in only this
specific honors degree, than
in my regular business degree.
But the learnings and insights
I got from them were so
tremendous and really helped me so much
in all the years after that,
that I would not have wanted to miss that.
What really also helped
me both personally,
but also professionally is to do as many
internships as possible.
So during the semester,
I even skipped weeks
and months of lectures,
just to do additional internships,
expose myself to new situations,
working in new companies
and new environments.
Some of them also abroad,
even in other continents.
So clearly from that, I
did not only learn a lot.
It really also helped me develop myself
and surely this was then also
instrumental to the later,
for instance getting the
internship at McKinsey,
which then helped me to start
my career as a consultant.
On top of that, I would
argue that even starting
this YouTube channel early last year
is an example of doing
things off the beaten path.
So clearly starting a YouTube
channel is not something that
everyone else in your environment will do.
I'm also not recommending
all of you to do this.
But for me, it just was a leap of faith,
earlier last year to do this,
I definitely learned so much,
just from producing these videos to you.
And definitely this also
already opened up many
opportunities for me personally,
just by regularly
bringing these videos out
and hopefully adding some
value to you by doing that.
As you know, the famous Steve Jobs quote,
you can only connect the dots backwards.
Who knows what it will be good for,
if you follow a maybe exotic
hobby during university
or during your twenties,
the only thing that you know,
for certain like things
that you do not do will,
definitely not be able to
help you later down the road.
My second reflection is
on the value of your time.
So definitely at least most
people in their twenties,
especially why they're
still at university,
but often also in the
more entry level careers,
especially if you're not
working in a high paced career
like banking or consulting,
you will like you have a lot of time.
And if not during the day,
than at least in the evenings.
And here especially the time
that you have in the evenings,
I truly believe that how you use that.
Will very much determine your
life in the next five years,
in the next 10 years.
So think about the last days,
how do you use your time in the evenings?
And I know it can feel hard
after a long day at work.
If you're coming home at 6:00 PM, 7:00 PM,
8:00 PM, 9:00 PM being at home,
you often feel exhausted.
So surely it feels great
to sit in front of the TV,
to watch Netflix, to spend
time with your friends,
with your family.
And I'm not saying that
you should not do that.
So clearly it is so important
to recharge your batteries,
spend time with your loved ones.
This is definitely
something you should do.
Though this is just the truth.
If every evening you sit at home,
watch Netflix, your life in five years,
your life in 10 years
will look very different,
compared to if you use the time
to do something productive,
maybe work on a side business
on additional like idea that
can maybe grow into something bigger.
Maybe even just spend
time with a great hobby,
maybe you like photography,
maybe like videography.
And here it's not even necessary
to always have a big master plan
of what will come out of these things.
So let's think about photography.
Maybe you just started as a hobby
and then spend time in the evenings,
researching the topic, learning about it,
getting some experience in practice.
But maybe then in the future,
you develop this into
a little side business,
where you do photography for maybe
weddings or other things.
And this is just an additional source
of side income that
you really enjoy doing.
Or maybe you start a YouTube channel
talking about your insights, your hobby,
what you learned from that,
and thereby helping other people.
Or maybe by learning about
the photography industry.
You suddenly have a business idea.
An idea for a start-up
that you can now develop
and now you can get yourself into.
And that might help you
to quit your regular
nine to five job and
become an entrepreneur,
create a business out of that.
So once again, it's not always
possible in that very moment
to know what certain
activities will be good for,
later down the road.
The only thing that's certain
is that if you just spend this
time watching Netflix and
movies, every single evening,
surely here, nothing good
will come out of that.
Surely this will not help
you, to improve your life,
five years, 10 years later down the road.
Last but not least let's
talk about investing.
So you hear one thing
I hear quite commonly
from people in their 20's is to say,
why should I save money?
It's much harder for me to save a little
bit of money right now.
Why shouldn't I just start saving money
and investing in my
thirties where I likely will have earned
much more money were likely than saving
a little bit of my earnings,
will be much easier to me
than now in my twenties.
Maybe still a student or in my first job,
still I don't have a
lot of money it's just
so much more difficult.
And to be frank, I used to think like that
in my early twenties as well.
But thankfully over time,
my mindset on this changed a little bit.
And I have two answers,
two replies to that,
if you think like that as well.
The first is the value of habits,
the value of getting used to that.
So if you never really got any experience,
any habits in saving your money,
if you're just always spending it all,
it will be extremely
difficult for you to suddenly
in your thirties to start
saving a substantial
amount of your income every single month,
just to build your capital,
build your net worth.
This would be so much more
difficult to you instead
of if you even only with
small sums maybe 50 bucks
or so every single month, as a student
you are already putting aside
in an investment account
and then develop this habit
from a very early age.
But I would even object to the
second point that right now,
it doesn't even matter if you're only save
and invest small amounts of money.
And what people here really underestimate
is the power of accumulating interests.
And there are some really
mind blowing calculation,
examples out there to what an effect,
even saving small amounts of
money in your twenties can have
to your long-term accumulation of wealth
and long-term accumulation of net worth.
Investing only small amounts of money
like a hundred or 200 euro,
every single month can really snowball
into much more significant
amounts later down the road.
Or to put it differently,
if you compare the net worth
of someone who only starts
investing in his or her thirties,
compared to someone who starts already
investing in their twenties,
the amount of additional money
that the person in his or her
thirties needs to put into the savings
and investments account
every single month,
just to be on the same page
with someone who already
started investing in his or her twenties
is really mind blowing.
So there are lots of calculation,
examples like that.
I will link here about a video,
where I talk about the
importance of saving.
Also share one of these examples.
Were I can hopefully have a
better understanding of that.
If you doubt that if you doubt
that there is value in saving
even small amounts of
money in your twenties,
watch this video.
And I hope that this
convinces you to do otherwise,
but now let me hear from you.
What are your insights, reflections,
lessons from your twenties?
Please leave a comment
in the comment section,
where you share these
insights with the overall
Firm Learning community.
Trust this will be helpful to many,
many people watching out there.
So as always, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
hit the like button for
the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to this channel
and turn on notifications.
To stay up to date with all of my content.
I'm also on other platforms
such as LinkedIn, Instagram,
TikToK and Twitch, feel
free to follow me there.
You'll find links to my social it's below
in the video description.
And if this is still not enough,
I also have an email
newsletter with weekly content,
signup link to that in the
video description as well.
And also want to say a big,
big thank you to all the
members of, Firm Learning.
Thanks so much for your contribution.
My name is Heinrich,
I'm the creator here of Firm Learning.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to talk
to you again next week.
Until then good weekend to all of you,
all the best here from Germany.
Bye-bye.